KARIM LAKHANI: Whether you're
developing a new product or strategy,
responding to the changing workforce,
or simply looking for new ideas,
crowdsourcing and open innovation
allow you to find answers and solutions
in areas you didn't expect.
This course presents a foundational
understanding of open innovation,
helping you not only solve some
of your most difficult problems,
but also gain access to a
pool of talent that goes
far beyond your organization's walls.
Through videos, real world case
studies, and peer interaction,
you will explore when and why
to implement crowdsourcing,
how to operationalize
it, and most importantly,
how to identify the problem
you're trying to solve.
JIN PAIK: What we see
with open innovation
and crowdsourcing is that
as new architecture rises,
to be able to use the
component knowledge to be
able to access new talent, new
tools, new ways of doing things.
LUIS VILLA: Having an open-source
team, open-source strategy as a company
is very much seen now as a hiring
or recruiting strategy, as well.
LYNN BUQUO: There is a
complete change in attitude
about what the benefit of being
open can bring to the agency.
I see it at all levels
of the agency now.
KARIM LAKHANI: The world is
full of amazing people that
are scattered around the
globe, and open innovation
allows you to systematically
get access to these people
and help your company
and your organization
solve their most difficult challenges.
In open innovation, the
world becomes your lab.